ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Hi everyone.
We're here at Devoxx 2014 in
beautiful Antwerp, Belgium.
It's kind of cold
today, actually.
And I'm here with my guest
to talk about Chrome Apps
everywhere.
And maybe you can
introduce yourself.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Sure.
So my name's Andrew Grieve,
and I work on the Chrome Apps
for Mobile project.
Yeah, I've been doing web
development for the past six
years at Google, and it's
always an exciting time.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Yeah.
The web is an exciting place.
And it's always a good time
to be developing for the web.
So Chrome apps and mobile,
so these are probably
the two things we'll talk about.
The first one, Chrome apps.
Can you maybe redefine this for
those that haven't heard of it
or need a refresh.
How do they differ from web
pages or web extensions?
ANDREW GRIEVE: Sure.
Sure.
So Chrome apps have
had-- it's actually
a fairly short history.
As we know them
today for desktop,
they were only made
available late 2012,
so only a couple years old.
And the big difference
from web pages
is really that they don't
run within a browser tab.
So they have to run
in their own window,
and this distinguishes
them from regular web apps.
So you get them through
the Chrome Web Store.
They are downloaded
and installed.
And the main reason why you'd
want them over a regular web
app is that they have permission
to use more powerful APIs,
so things like the user's
identity, raw sockets,
or synced storage, some really
more powerful and compelling
APIs.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So there
are two things you mentioned.
The first is the
actual-- its own window.
It probably means it
can be totally immersive
and you don't really
know it is powered
by a web engine or
a rendering engine?
ANDREW GRIEVE: Right.
That's right.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Maybe
you want to comment about that.
And second question is
about the security aspect.
It is very secure, though.
Although it has those
additional powers and APIs
to access the
hardware and all that,
it is very secure
at the same time.
So maybe you want to
comment on those two things.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yeah.
So as you were saying, not only
do they run outside of a tab,
but they run as their own window
and separate from the browser.
So that means they have
their own desktop icon,
they have their
own Alt tab entry.
And to most users, they'd
be really hard pressed
to figure out that they were
built on web technology.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Yeah.
They're very-- there's
native integration
with the OS,
whichever OS that is.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Exactly.
And as far security goes,
you also are right on point
there as well, that
in general, they
are more secure than typical
desktop applications.
I mean, a large part of
that is just because it's
built by the Chrome team,
and I've really never
been on a team more
paranoid, I guess,
about security than
the Chrome team.
So all the apps
run in sandboxes.
And there's really
locked-down capabilities
of what they can do.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So there's a content security
policy that's-- you
need to have one.
You can't run without one.
A regular website could,
but a Chrome app cannot.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Right.
So content security policy is
a fairly new HTML5 kind of API
that's come out in it.
And it is available for
use on the open web.
But it's an opt-in thing.
So for Chrome Apps, the
difference is it's not opt-in.
You must use it.
And it really just helps prevent
mostly against XSS attacks.
And the rationale
there is really
just because we're giving you
these more capable and powerful
APIs, so the risk is kind
of even greater to attacks.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And part of these things,
Chrome apps have been out
for a little while already.
We have good examples of popular
apps that have been built
and that people are using.
But what is new, I would
think, is the ability
to build mobile apps nowadays
with the same technology.
Oh, and by the way,
Chrome apps are
being built with
web technologies,
as I think people have
understood by now.
It's all about
JavaScript, HTML5, CSS.
So take those skills
that you have,
those tools that
you have to build
desktop-like apps, but
also mobile apps nowadays.
So how does that work?
ANDREW GRIEVE: Right.
So that is what I'm more
intimately familiar with.
That's what I've been working
on for the past two years.
So Chrome Apps for
Mobile is actually
just still in a
developer preview phase.
So there are some, I think,
pretty compelling apps being
built with it currently, but
it's still hot off the press.
And you can mostly think of
that as a Cordova application.
There's not a huge difference
between a Chrome App
for Mobile application and
a regular Apache Cordova
application.
So Apache Cordova is a
fairly long-lived project,
which makes it easy to
create HTML and JavaScript
applications and deploy
them to mobile platforms,
as true native apps but
built with web technology.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: So how
would that differ from me
building, say, an Android
native app using a WebView?
ANDREW GRIEVE: So actually it
wouldn't differ all that much.
So Cordova applications,
in general,
are a WebView taking
up the entire page
and rendering your UI that way.
So the biggest
difference, I would say,
is it provides an
abstraction that
lets you target
multiple platforms.
So iOS, Android
is what we support
on Chrome Apps for Mobile, and
then Cordova itself supports
pretty much every
mobile operating
system that you can think of.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
But do you
need to develop to
some very lowest
common denominator in terms
of what a WebView can support?
I know one of the nice,
very new features,
I believe, in Android is the
fact that the Chrome WebView is
now something that
is being updated
on a very regular basis.
It's been externalized.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Right.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
You get
take benefits of having WebGL in
the Chrome WebView on Android.
You may not be able to do
this on all the platforms.
So how does a developer
deal with that?
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yes so
this was historically
a really kind of growing
problem for the project
for a long time.
And it's only
recently kind of been
addressed in a meaningful way.
So I'm really happy
to say that there
is a meaningful answer here.
So like you said,
as with Android L
this system WebView
is based on Chromium,
I believe M37 at launch,
and it is updatable outside
of Android updates.
That's awesome.
The iOS WebView,
as of iOS 8, they
came up with a
brand new WebView.
Now it has accelerated
JavaScript and WebGL as well.
So very capable there.
And iOS system updates
are quite well adopted.
Of course the question
still is, what
about people that aren't
running Android L, which
has been out for
approximately one day now.
So our answer, at least,
there is the Intel Crosswalk
open source project, which
is a bundling of the Chromium
WebView inside your application.
So there's a couple trade-offs,
mainly the size of it.
It adds about 17 megabytes
to your APK size.
But for most, we haven't
heard that this is actually
a big problem.
And it lets you use the
latest and greatest WebView
on all Android targets.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So walk us maybe a little bit
through the workflow,
the tooling, the APIs.
I want to start
my "Hello, World,"
and probably move a
little bit beyond that
and build my first Chrome
App-based mobile app.
What does it take?
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yeah.
So there's a couple
of options there.
I'd say the easiest just for
building a "Hello, World,"
and toying around
a little bit is
to use the Chrome Dev Editor.
So this is, again,
a project that
was announced at the last
Google I/O this summer.
And it's an ID which is actually
built as a Chrome app itself.
So that's kind of cool as
a technology demonstration.
But it's ID just for
building from Chrome Apps.
So there's templates in there.
There's a Play button.
If you click Play, it'll
open your application
as a desktop Chrome App.
And then if you use the
drop-down menu in our companion
tool for the Chrome App
Developer tool for mobile,
then there's a Deploy
to Mobile Device button.
So you could easily,
without installing any SDKs,
play around with what
your app would look like
both on mobile and on desktop.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Yeah.
So the time to
"Hello, World" is very
short in this-- I mean, no SDKs.
ANDREW GRIEVE: That's
the quickest path
to a "Hello, World," for sure.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And eventually, I
do build this awesome app.
And I just package this
and distribute this
through traditional Play
stores or Apple stores.
Right?
That's how it works.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yeah.
Yeah.
For mobile, exactly.
So the App Store and iOS or
the Play store on Android.
Once you get past your
typical "Hello, World,"
you want to install
our command line tools.
So we have-- Cordova's
tools are based on Node.js,
as are ours, for
Chrome Apps for Mobile.
And we give you kind of
a Ruby on Rails style--
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Scaffolding.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yeah, exactly.
You can do-- CCA is
the name of the tool.
So cca Create Project,
cca Build Android.
And that's about
the extent of it,
so you need to install your SDKs
at this point for this tool.
But then we give you a
nice wrapper around them
to just say cca build
Android, cca build iOS.
And then that's what you
upload to the stores.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: And I'm
pretty sure having
command line also
helps with continuous
integration
and integrating this in
any build environment
and development environment
that developers have.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yeah.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So web developers
love using frameworks
or libraries, whatever
you want to call them.
Does Chrome Apps
recommend against
or to use some
libraries, if any,
especially in the mobile case?
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yeah.
I mean, that's
mostly a question we
try to stay out of a little bit.
There's new frameworks
popping up all the time.
I'd say our project
goal is to give you
the awesomest, most
powerful blank canvas
to work with as possible.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Right.
So you're not
mandating anything.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Exactly.
So Polymer, I think,
is a promising project.
Angular, I've had
good times with.
Ionic is a really popular
Angular-based framework
for Cordova-based
applications, which
works just fine for
Chrome Apps for Mobile.
I mean, my personal advice
is to spend the time
to at least understand what
these frameworks are doing.
But I wouldn't say I have
a strong preference for any
of them.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Choice is good.
I like choice.
So maybe to close off, you're
here presenting at Devoxx.
And I think you also have some
tips or information about what
kind of paradigm
works for developers.
Maybe mobile apps.
I mean, the things
that really work well,
things that don't work all
that well that people shouldn't
maybe use yet or at
all, because it's just
not the way they should build
things in this environment.
Do you want to tell
us more about this?
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yeah.
So I do have kind of developer
guidance, I would say,
tips and tricks in my talk.
Mostly I'd say what
works well is just--
the main thing I
find is just make
sure you have that fast feedback
loop when you're developing.
And that's kind of one of the
best things about developing
for the web platform
wherever you are.
So for Cordova applications,
the main trick there
is to remember that
you're building using web,
so it doesn't take much to
make your mobile application
run on a desktop browser.
And Chrome Dev
Tools emulation mode
gives you a really
easy way to make
Chrome pretend like
it's a mobile device
and shrink your view
port and whatnot.
It's really fast and convenient.
So it's no replacement
for testing on device,
but it certainly makes
for a compelling workflow.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Great.
So what is the status of
this project altogether?
I mean, can people use it today?
And would you recommend
people shipping
apps built on top of that today?
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yeah.
So I'd say every application
has different requirements.
Certainly for some, this would
be a perfectly reasonable
platform to use today.
There are some rough edges
around us finishing up
the Crosswalk
integration, for example.
For example, we
haven't yet updated cca
to support the iPhone
6 Plus icon sizes.
So we'll have that done probably
next week, some rough edges.
But I'd say for the
most part, we're ready.
We've responded quickly to
our bug tracker on GitHub.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And this
is a good time to mention that
this is a fully open source
project.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yes.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So if people
want to support, help, or at
least know what's going on,
it's done in the open.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Exactly.
Yeah.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
Well thank you, Andrew.
That's, I guess, all
the time we have for it.
So thank you for
answering my questions.
And we'll be seeing you soon.
Online probably.
ANDREW GRIEVE: All right.
Thanks.